soir à vous aussi bonsoir j'ai on a reçu
des centaines de questions page et je
dis aux gens jeudi dernier il n'y a pas
de gêne le yes papa ce que parce que des
fois on va trop vite et on prend pour
acquis beaucoup de choses alors j'ai
cette question pour vous puis je vais
vous pressez le poc cas vous pouvez des
foyers on n'a pas de réponse claire je
commence
serait-il possible que la lenteur et les
difficultés de l'avancée des troupes
russes ne soit qu'une ruse pour mieux
attaquer éventuellement demandent
lysanne la salle je m'assis grand avec
vous
je crois que là sinon elle est plutôt
claire delalande rare elle est due à la
résistance du crédit et non pas une
volonté d or de bosc de retour à lens
c'est vraiment ce qu'on a sous-estimé
les forces l'ukrainienne que ça prend
quand il ya des gens en face pourquoi ya
pas qui allait en avoir fait la d'accord
absolument bon qui va payer les gens
m'ont dit c'est une question qui va se
poser plus tard mais quart mais qui va
payer pour la reconstruction la russie
demande stéphane pichette
raphaël oui patrice une question qui va
se poser plus tard donc je vais
apprendre plus tard voulait des réponses
brèves en voilà une ok donc on n'est pas
là du tout on est volé du tout juste 1
to
moi je dirais que ce n'est pas la partie
qui contrôlera l'ukraine à l'assaut de
la guerre l'état qui vont contrôler le
persil par exemple de leers va être sous
la responsable d'erreurs 6 t elle mais
conserve les ukrainiens réussissent à
dire d'une partie territoire et
d'indépendance ce sera pas si le mâle
l'occident au canada aux états unis qui
va les aider à reconstruire très bien on
revienne
l'origine en tout cas un des points
d'origine du conflit jean-luc cousineau
qui demande à quel moment l'ukraine a
fait sa demande d'adhésion à l'otan
quels sont les critères pour accepter
cette demande sur quels critères y at il
des bords et quels sont les pays qui s'y
opposait ou qui s'y opposent justin
excellente question donc c'est au sommet
de bucarest 2008 à qu'on a inscrit
l'ukraine au plan d'adhésion dont une
éventuelle promesses d'adhésion qui
était rien
deux premiers parce que plusieurs
critères effectivement démocratie
respect des minorités ne pas avoir de
conflit sur son territoire par exemple
de régler sans la violence les
différences quelques jours pose un
obstacle et donc lit ça fonctionne par
consensus la d11 si l'auteur allemagne
notamment la france s'opposait à ce que
l'ukraine rejoigne le temps pourquoi
parce qu'on craignait que les russes
étaient pour réagir en avalisant
donc rafael là dessus sur ce dernier
point français-allemand il savait qu'il
y avait un côté provocation si on dit
oui absolument ce une réponse parfaite
la seule chose que j'ajouterai c'est que
le gouvernement américain gouverner à
l'époque par le président bush s'était
fait très explicitement averti à la fois
par madame merkel par le gouvernement
français et par leurs propres services
de renseignement ne fait pas ça n'allait
pas attendre cette perche à l'ukraine
parce que c'est trop dangereux par
rapport à moscou président américain de
l'époque n'a pas été bon et quand les
gens disent à ce que vous venez de dire
eiffel et d'autre ça ne veut pas dire
que c'est une caution de ce que fait
vladimir sociale si on explique qu'il ya
des raisons historiques qui font que
quelqu'un qui est dans le coin peu des
foires des réactions totalement
démesurée bon et on connaît la suite
j'amène la fontaine qu'est ce que
vladimir poutine gagnera à conquérir un
pays que des millions de personnes ont
fui
et donc plusieurs institutions immeubles
seront détruits justin
c'est vraiment difficile à comprendre
notre point de vue là ici au canada
c'est cette idée de redonner la grandeur
à la russie de créer sa sphère d
influence pour plusieurs russes il
voyait l'ukraine comme une source de
menace à leur sécurité tout le narratif
qui se passe présentement sur la tv
d'état en russie dit que c'est l'ukraine
qui est là qu est la menace et l'ukraine
qui attaquent la russie donc c'est dur
pour nous parce qu'on sait que c'est pas
du tout ça la réalité mais c'est ça qui
était vraiment véhiculées dans les
médias c'est ça le raisonnement qui dit
par monsieur poutine et lui se voit
encore comme celui qui pourrait redonner
la grande redonnez lempire à la russie
par cette invasion redonner enfin jacob
la force à cette grande nation qu'il
représente et lui se voit comme le seul
le seul assez fort pour le faire re
donner la force à la russie et surtout
et ça c'est fondamental surtout empêcher
l'ukraine de tomber dans le giron
occidental le mot conquête tel qui est
utilisé dans la question s'applique
seulement si vous voyez l'admet poutine
comme quelqu'un justement qui veut
reconstruire l'empiré soviétique si vous
le regardez de façon plus immédiat si
l'objectif fondamental c'est d'empêcher
l'ukraine de devenir une démocratie
fonctionnelle un pays membre de l'union
européenne un pays membre de l'otan on
n'a pas nécessairement besoin d'aimer de
le conquérir on a peut-être seulement et
je sais que c'est faisable a dirigé les
mentionner à au panel vendredi je le
rappelle on ne peut pas être simplement
dans le court terme besoin de le
détruire ce pays là dont il sera gardé
en tête
une question je vous demandais je sais
c'est là ça va être juste un jeu
joueuses va toucher de faire ce que font
les partis d'opposition au parlement
ukrainien il y avait des partis pro
russe dans le parlement bain qui quels
sont leurs positions à ce que se sont
ralliés alors président craignais où ils
sont pros re ce justin
ils se sont ralliés récemment ils ont
émis un communiqué en disant qu il
voulait que la russie titre le
territoire ukrainien qui voulons un
cessez le feu qu'il fallait donc
redonner l'indépendance à l'ukraine il
ya vraiment eu un changement et ce sera
définitif la guerre a rallié les
ukrainiens autour de leur désir de
souveraineté leur désir des parents donc
c'est contre-productif ce côté russe et
c'est intéressant et la gale poutine a
galvanisé tous les ukrainiens même ceux
qui étaient poreuses une certaine façon
raffin je passe à l'autre question
quelles sont les relations des pays de
l'asie de l'afrique l'amérique du sud
avec les russes existe il des liens
économiques permettant ainsi demande
michel turgeon de financer la guerre
ruche et vous voulez évidemment une
réponse brève avouer qu'ils sont là qui
est pour le moins complexe ça dépend de
quel pays on parle simplement je donne
un exemple amérique latine tout il ya
plusieurs pays en amérique latine mais
ils ne sont pas tous créés égaux en
termes d'influencé une influence
économique par exemple le brésil qui
numéro un en termes de pib à peu près
quatre fois le pib du pays numéro 2
l'argentine dont ça dépend de quoi on
parle et j'ai juste citer l'exemple du
brésil justement parce qu'il est
intéressant très peu de gens en parlent
la relation entre le président brésilien
bastareaud et celle avec l'ex président
américain dans l'ordre ont pensé était
très proche plusieurs la critique et aux
états unis en fait comme étant trop
proche depuis l'arrivée de joe biden sas
et je voudrais un petit peu refroidi et
au compteur le brésil a été un des pays
qui s'est abstenue de condamner
l'invasion russe de l'ukraine ça ne veut
pas dire que c'est un allié naturel de
la russie ça revient à dire que c'est
extrêmement complexe et là j'ai un
semblant de vous parler du poison de ces
régions là et j'en parlais de la chine
justin s'est pas exactement je la laisse
à justin absolument voilà c'est l'acteur
incontournable c'est celui qui peut
permettre à la russie de possiblement
contourner les sanctions mais on voit
que la chine tempère ses ardeurs parce
que l ex aussi propre bande aussi aux
sanctions économiques imposées par
l'union européenne et les etats-unis est
jusqu'à présent une forme de neutralité
pro-russe c'est-à-dire très ambigu sur
ce qu'elle va faire on sait que la
russie a demandé des armes ou si
récemment donc à la chine elle a dit
qu'elle explorait l'idéal par hp
mécontents les sanctions de quelle
espèce de joux l'essai de jouer sur la
dernière question pourquoi le canada
n'envoie pas des avions humanitaires
pour des dons faire un pont aérien pour
les réfugiés directement sur place au
lieu de les faire voyager encore plus
loin dans d'autres pays d'europe
raphaël est plutôt acheté un lapsus
comme en plus les questions là
moi je trouve que c'est une excellente
question parce que pour beaucoup de
l'une des grandes choses que le canada
peut france les actions humanitaires on
a de la place au pays on sait qu'il ya
une bonne communauté ukrainienne sous
pays on aimerait que le gouvernement
aille plus loin donc on qui lève
possiblement lévisien on a accéléré la
formule mais il faut quand même aller
sur internet et des formulaires d'andré
attendait à travers du transfert donc je
pense qu'ils auraient moyens de faire
plus et la seule explication qu'on a eu
jusqu'à présent 2 du gouvernement
canadien c'est con craindrait qui est
des éléments pro russe qui profiterait
qui sait je dirais comme réfugiés
profiterait de ce pont à rien ne pas
venir au canada pour le moins nébuleux
comme histoire à mon avis très bien vous
avez été exemplaire devrait être prof il
reste 40 secondes est ce que vous avez
de l'espoir vous quand vous avez entendu
hier justin je reprends avec vous après
on conclut raphaël que là il ya quand
même on continue à se parler quand même
justin
on vraiment souffle le chaud et le froid
il y avait des rapprochements donc les
deux parties disait qu'on était proche
peut-être dans quelques jours on pourra
avoir un accord peut-être de cessez le
feu et aujourd'hui ce qu'on apprend
c'est que les russes disent mon maintien
nous mêmes objectifs non même l'ambition
on voit pas retirer nos troupes pas
qu'on ne va pas fleix plier les villes
très bien raphaël j'ai plutôt un jeu
vous leur donnerait la prochaine fois
raphaël justin merci beaucoup très clair
et mesdames et messieurs continue je
donnerai les adresses après merci bonne
fin de soirée